dans l'histoire des mathématiques il y a
eu peu de débats aussi rocambolesqu et
mouvementés que celui sur la stabilité
du système solaire pendant plus de tris
siècles des génération de génie de
Newton à vilan en passant par Eiler la
grange la place Point Carré colmogorov
et lascar entre autres ont enchaîner les
approximations les erreurs les théorèmes
positifs presque conclusifs les
théorèmes négatifs presque conclusifs et
même les appels à Dieu souvent en
réussissant à convaincre leurs
contemporains mais en échouant presque
systématiquement face à l'épreuve du
temps
peu de conclusions mathématiques sont
resté aussi longtemps instables que
celles qui cherchaient à trancher la
question de la stabilité du système
solaire et ce n'est pas matador auteur
d'une excellente vidéo à ce sujet qui me
contredira alors non c'est sûr je vais
pas te contredire c'est clairement un
des sujets mathématiques les plus
passionnants que j'ai eu à traiter et on
va parler de ton excellent récit de
l'histoire de cette question en fin de
vidéo moi ce qui va m'intéresser dans
cette histoire c'est un élément que je
t'ai demandé de laisser de côté pour que
j'y consacre une vidéo à part entière à
savoir une prédiction faite non pas par
Newton non pas par Eiler h la grange euh
Point
Carré reviens en
arrière et oui la place encore lui la
place comme on va le voir la place avait
fait en 1814 une prédiction tellement
folle que lui-même la reniait pour de
très bonnes raisons cependant si on
adapte sa prédiction au découverte de la
physique du début du 20e siècle et si on
déroule les arguments de la place on en
vient à effectuer à peu près la même
conclusion que celle des mathématiques
les plus célébrés du 21e siècle à savoir
les prédictions de lascar et le plus fou
c'est que ces arguments de la place ne
font absolument pas intervenir la
physique mais pour comprendre les
arguments de la place de 1814 il nous
faut revenir quelques décennies en
arrière en 1774 un jeune la placeace de
25 ans écrit l'une de ses premières
contributions scientifiques intitulé
mémoire sur la probabilité des causes
par les événements cet écrit de 38 pages
est une véritable révolution non
seulement mathématique mais surtout
épistémologique en tout cas à mes yeux
car derrière ces apparences
mathématiques ce titre soulève
clairement une question fondamentale de
la philosophie que doit-on penser des
causes d'un événement lorsque cet
événement est observé si un patient a un
symptôme d'une maladie peut-on conclure
qu'il a la maladie en question et si un
homme meurt après être vacciné est-ce à
cause de sa vaccination pour répondre à
ces questions la place propose dans ce
mémoire un principe fondateur je cite si
un événement peut être produit par un
nombre n de causes différentes les
probabilités de l'existence de ces
causes prises de l'événement sont entre
elles comme les probabilités de
l'événement prise de ces causes et la
probabilité de l'existence de chacune
d'elles est égale à la probabilité de
l'événement prise de cette cause divisé
par la somme de toutes les probabilités
de l'événement pris de chacune de ces
causes si un événement peut être produit
par un nombre n de cause
différent bon je vais le reconnaître
l'écriture du jeune la place est loin
d'être la plus limpide qui soit j'ai
personnellement dû relire ce paragraphe
plusieurs fois pour le comprendre et on
va dire que mon bagage mathématique et
les exemples qui suivent dans le mémoire
m'ont beaucoup aidé ont été même d'une
aide vitale pour y arriver mais du coup
je vais me permettre de reformuler la
place do Pier Simon ce que dit la place
c'est que plus une cause prédit
l'événement observé plus elle devient
relativement plus crédible par rapport à
une cause qui prédit mal l'événement
observé en fait la formulation formelle
de ce que dit la place c'est ni plus ni
moins la fameuse formule de Bay dont je
crois vous avoir déjà un petit peu parlé
ainsi si la mort d'un homme vacciné
s'explique par d'autres causes bien plus
probables il reste en fait peu probable
que la vaccination en soit la cause
armée de son nouveau principe
épistémologique la place s'attaque à une
généralisation du fameux problème de
l'induction de Hume imaginons que le
soleil se lève tous les jours peut-on
alors prédire qu'il se lèvera encore
demain la place va modéliser ce problème
par un autre problème plus abstrait
imaginez une urne opaque contenant un
très grand nombre de billets noirs et
blancs mais vous ne savez pas quelle est
la fraction de billets noirs dans cette
urne vous tirez maintenant un A1 un
certain nombre de ces billets imaginez
que vous ayez alors retiré P billet
blanc et Q billet noir quelle est la
probabilité que le prochain billet tiré
de l'urne soit blanc clairement le cas
particulier ou Q = 0 décrit le problème
de Hume si on considère que un billet
blanc est un jour où le soleil s'est
levé et où P est alors le nombre de fois
que le soleil s'est levé quelle est dans
ce cas la probabilité que le soleil se
lèvera demain quelle est la probabilité
que le prochain billet tiré soit blanc
lui
aussi pour répondre à cette question la
place propose d'appeler x la fraction
inconnue de billets blanc dans l'urne
puis il considère un a priori uniforme
sur X tout ce qu'il sait c'est que X est
entre 0 et 1 et il consid considère a
priori qu'une valeur x autour de 0,5 est
aussi probable qu'une valeur autour de
0,99 notez que X peut alors être
considéré comme la cause de chaque
événement observé à savoir la couleur
des billets tirés ainsi si un billet
tiré est blanc et bien la cause c'est
sans doute que X est grand le problème
est alors bien un problème d'induction
il s'agit de déterminer les probabilités
des causes à savoir les valeurs de X par
les événements à savoir les nombres p et
q de billets blanc et noir tirés et pour
cela comme les explique le principe de
la place il nous faut d'abord estimer la
probabilité des événements par les
causes autrement dit sachant x quelle
est la probabilité de tirer P billet
blanc et Q billet noir à l'époque de la
place il s'agissait alors là déjà d'une
question classique déjà répondu par
Pascal pu bernoui je ne vais pas rentrer
dans le détail mais la réponse est de la
forme F qui dépend de P et Q x x^ P x 1
- x pu Q ou F qui dépend de P et Q est
ce qu'on appelle un coefficient binomial
qu'on note aussi parfois P + Q en haut
et P en bas et qu'on lit P parmi P + Q
mais comme vous allez voir ces détails
importent en fait très peu d're cas
désormais pour déterminer la probabilité
d'une cause X par les événements p et q
la place nous dit qu'il faut comparer ce
terme à la somme des termes similaires
pour les autres causes possibles x'e
comme il y a une infinité de valeurs
possibles de X prime plutôt qu'une somme
classique il va nous falloir prendre une
somme continue qu'on appelle aussi
intégrale dans le jargon mathématique et
là j'envoie deux au fond là qui font
ah c'était ça une intégrale ainsi la
probabilité d'une cause x sachant P et Q
est donné par F PQ x x^ p/ 1 - x^ Q
divisé par l'intégrale D F de PQ x y^ P
x 1 - y^ Q dy B pour ceux qui connaiss
pas les intégrales tout ce que j'ai fait
c'est remplacer symboliquement la lettre
X prime par la lettre Y et on met un dy
pour pour dire que c'est une somme sur Y
en gros notez que les coefficients
binomiaux s'annulent si bien que la
probabilité de X est simplement x^ P x 1
- x^ Q divisé par l'intégrale de y^ P 1
- y^ Q dy en fait on peut même faire la
remarque que le dénominateur est une
constante indépendante de X et ne dépend
en fait uniquement que de P et Q si bien
que la probababilité de la cause x
s'écrit plus simplement x^iss P x 1 -
x^iss Q divisé par une fonction B de P
et Q de NS jours cette probabilité est
ce qu'on appelle sous le nom de loi
betta et la loi betta est d'ailleurs
très chouette notamment pour les basens
maintenant si la cause est x alors la
probabilité que le prochain billet qu'on
tire soit blanc sera égale à X puisque x
c'est la fraction de billet blanc dans
l'urne mais chaque cause X n'a qu'une
probabilité x^ P x 1 - x pu Q divis par
B de P et Q pour connaître la
probabilité de tirer un billet blanc la
place propose de de cumuler les
probabilités selon les différentes
causes possibles on parle parfois de
probabilité totale ainsi la probabilité
qui résulte de différentes causes
possible mais maintenant pondéré par
leur degré de plusibilité ça nous donne
l'intégrale de X fois la probabilité de
X sachant les observations p et q x DX
et ça c'est l' inégrale de x^ P + 1 x 1
- x pu Q DX divis par B de P et Q et
alors là il y a des calculs intégrals à
faire et je vais passer ces détails sous
calcul mais la place lui les a fait
soigneusement et d'ailleurs s'il y a des
étudiants parmi vous je vous invite à
faire ces calculs explicitement vous
aussi mais toujours est-il que si on
fait tous les calculs on aboutit à la
conclusion que la probabilité que le
prochain billet tiré soit blanc selon
les principes platiens cette probabilité
est égal à P + 1/ P + Q + 2 cette
formule est ce qu'on appelle désormais
la loi de succession de la place et
comme l'explique très bien THB and brown
elle s'est retrouvé au cœur de
nombreuses applications notamment sur le
web
we en résolvant son problème d'urn la
place fournit ainsi également une
solution au fameux problème de
l'induction de hum quelle est la
probabilité que le soleil se lève encore
demain il suffit de compter le nombre de
jours P où il s'est levé jusque là puis
de faire le calcul P + 1 div par P + Q +
2 avec la valeur particulière de Q est
égale à 0 et on obtient alors P + 1/ par
P + 2 dès lors la probabilité qu'il ne
se lève pas et donc qu'un cataclysme
stellaire empêche qui peut nous paraître
inévitable sera donné par 1/ par P + 2
en particulier si la probabilité que le
soleil ne se lève pas est en effet 1
divis par P + 2 et si chaque prochain
levé de soleil est statistiquement
indépendant du précédent il nous faut
nous attendre à ce que le soleil arrête
de se lever dans environ P plus de jours
ouais si vous pensez comme Franck que
ces calcul de la place sont farfelu vous
n'êtes pas les seuls la place même les
avait à effectuer en prenant l'hypothèse
religieuse selon laquelle l'histoire
aurait commencé il y a 5000 ans soit
1826213 jours et ça ça l'a amené à
conclure que je cite il y a
1826214 à parier contre un qu'il se
lèvera encore demain ou dit autrement
statistiquement le soleil pourrait
s'arrêter de se lever dans quelque chose
comme 5000 ans ceci étant dit la place
se précipite ensuite d'ajouter je cite
mais ce nombre est incomparablement plus
fort pour celui qui connaissant par
l'ensemble des phénom ain le principe
régulateur des jours et des saisons voit
que rien dans le mouvement actuel ne
peut en arrêter le cours autrement dit
selon la place sachant les connaissances
de la physique de l'époque les
prédictions de sa modélisation du
problème de Hume ne doivent pas être
prises pour archant contant et d'une
certaine manière en disant cela la place
ne fait qu'appliquer sa propre théorie
des probabilités en effet on a bien plus
de données à propos du soleil que le
simple fait qu'il se lève ou non en
particulier l'observation des
trajectoires des planètes du système
solaire nous a notamment conduit aux
lois de la gravité universelle de Newton
ignorer ses autres données pour
effectuer une prédiction serait
complètement irrationnelle par ailleurs
la place est en fait très loin d'être le
savant le plus croyant de l'histoire et
il y a de bonnes raisons de penser qu'il
ne croyait pas lui-même à l'hypothèse
religieuse selon laquelle l'histoire n'a
que 5000 ans et donc il a peut-être
écrit juste cela à titre illustratif et
de façon conforme aux croyances de ses
contemporains mais donc y a-t-il lieu de
complètement rejeter l'argument païsien
de la place et bien peut-être pas en
premier lieu on peut l'ajuster à l'état
des connaissances modernes on sait
maintenant que le système solaire est en
fait vieux de 5 milliards d'années de
sorte que le soleil s'estlevé 5
milliards de fois 365 jours de suite et
donc on serait amené à prédire que le
soleil pourra arrêter de se lever dans
environ 5 milliards d'années voire même
qu'il est peu probable que le soleil se
lève encore dans 50 milliards d'années
et ça roulement de tambourg ça ressemble
emble beaucoup à la conclusion de la
vidéo de matador Jacques lascar et les
différents chercheurs qui s'intéressent
à ce domaine n'ont pas d'autre choix que
de se fier à des modèles statistiques
sur 2500 trajectoires possibles parmi
elles une vingtaine donne lieu à ce que
l'ASCAR rappelle des instabilités fortes
comprenez par là des collisions
possibles entre les planètes selon lui
il y a 1 % de probabilité d'une
collision entre Mercure et Vénus sur 5
milliards d'années à venir mais cette
probabilité mon à 90 % sur 100 milliards
d'années un changement de 15 mm
seulement sur la trajectoire de mars
rendrait très proba des collisions entre
le Soleil et Mercure entre Mars et la
Terre la terre et Mercure parmi une
dizaine d'autres scénarioos poss
possible j'avoue impressionnant la place
d'autant que l'instabilité du système
solaire n'est que l'une des causes poss
possible de cette prédiction insensée du
modèle laplacien pour commencer le
soleil va finir lui-même par mourir dans
5 milliards d'années il va se
transformer en géant rouge puis en
nébuuse planétaire puis en aine blanche
et donc il y a peut-être lieu de dire
que en un sens le soleil aura arrêté de
se lever par ailleurs d'autres arguments
fondés sur l'énergie noire prédisent une
expansion fatale de l'espace-temps
appelée bigrip dans 22 milliards
d'années voilà donc plusieurs arguments
qui montrent que les ordres de grandeur
de l'incroyable prédiction de la fin du
monde de la place sont tout sauf
complètement déraisonnables en tout cas
il semble être bien plus qu'une simple
coïncidence littéralement
cosmique alors que retenir de cette
coïncidence cosmique y a-t-il vraiment
des choses à retenir pour nous autres
humains et nos vies quotidiennes et bien
oui certainement car le modèle laplacien
est beaucoup plus général que son
application cosmique en particulier le
principe qui consiste à supposer qu'un
événement vieux de X années va
probablement perdurer pendant encore X
années semble relativement fiable et
extrêmement applicable a de nombreuses
applications il est même utilisé
explicitement dans le show business où
il est connu sous le nom de effet de
Lind ou en gros chaque star qui a connu
le succès depuis 5 ans se dit qu'elle a
encore 5 ans de succès à connaître qui
plus est ce principe a en fait d'autres
justifications listé notamment dans mon
livre la formule du savoir ceci étant
dit comme tout Bazer il ne faut pas
s'arrêter à ce principe et bien
considérer l'ensemble de toutes les
données à notre disposition pour bien
raisonner un baayaisien doit prendre en
compte l'ensemble de ses connaissances
pour affiner ces prédictions et en
particulier dans le casadre de la
stabilité du système solaire je fais en
fait beaucoup plus confiance aux
prédictions de
lascar mais après il se trouve qu'elles
sont conformes à celles de la place la
place un énorme merci à Franck pour sa
collaboration sur ces vidéos je
recommande très vivement sa chaîne
matador en particulier il y a des vidéos
très chouettes sur des mathématiciens et
des mathématiciennes et recommande en
particulier sa vidéo sur Mariam
mirzakani ainsi que sa vidéo sur Sophie
Germain qui montre vraiment vraiment des
personnage fantastique de l'histoire des
mathématiques